what's going on reject nation i guess
this is the best way to end off the new
rockstars wanda vision videos
maybe just maybe this is one division
deleted scenes alternate ending revealed
uh the director did come out and speak
about some deleted scenes and an
alternate ending
and uh yeah i just kind of waited for
new rock stars to do their videos
man eric voss could break it down eric
boss thank you so much for shouting me
out in one of your inside marble videos
it's really special i love that thank
you buddy
i love you
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and one division's many mysteries
remain mysteries leaving folks like me
only with the scraps of my one division
vision board
that i tore down at 4 00 am friday
morning i'm kidding i love this ending i
love this show but
according to the series director this
finale episode actually featured a
deleted scene a kind of alternate indian
subplot involving the rabbit senor
scratchies
true demonic monstrous nature no prince
he was not a loose end he was a very
scary
real end so let's dive into what was
changed
and throughout this world he could have
had something come true stuff that was
tweaked
that you can actually see evidence for
if you're watching closely so
senor scratchy the rabbit pet of agatha
harkness was suspiciously built up
throughout the episode so much that many
of us believe that there had to have
been some deeper demonic secret to him
like his name senior scratch he could be
a nod to the devil's nickname
aka mephisto or a nod to agatha's son
from the comics nicholas scratch
and that might have been who feature was
obviously earth theories were all over
the place
rarely right and truly the friends we
made along the way but we did hold on to
the notion that this
rabbit wasn't just a rabbit he appeared
so prominently in that episode 2
animated intro and in key moments
throughout that episode
along with episode 7 with billy
mysteriously unable to read that rabbit
until the moment it was revealed it was
agatha all along
episode 8 dissolved from agatha's super
important origin flashback to
a close-up of this rabbit in real life
later in that scene of the feeds this
rabbit a bird
transmuted into an insect still a bit
weird since rabbits are mostly known to
be herbivores
right as this rabbit sits in front of an
open spellbook as if guarding it but
alas episode 8 was the last we saw of
senior scratchy
final cut of these episodes becoming one
of many unresolved mysteries about this
series
until director matt shachman went on
kevin smith and mark bernardin's batman
beyond show
and explained that senior scratchy was
actually supposed to have a much bigger
sequence in the finale what was affirmed
many of our observations
we did have something more uh planned
for senior scratchy which we ultimately
couldn't do just because the
finale we had so many different as i
said so many different chess pieces on
the
we did have a whole sequence where darcy
monica
ralph meet up with the kids and they're
all at this house and they
think that maybe they should steal the
darkhold um from the basement because
the kids had seen it when they were down
there
being held hostage by agatha they go
down there to get the book
and they're reaching for the book and
the rabbit hops up in front of the book
and they're like i don't think you're
scratchy he's the best and then like we
go
to pet him and he like hisses and then
this whole american werewolf in london
transformation happens
the rabbit turns into this big demon
right into her like familiarity
that would have been nutty absolutely
man
that would have been what a lot of us
were waiting for oh that was
that would have been one of the theories
come true for the most part
but they didn't have to confirm who
exactly senior scratchy was though right
not in this description anyway no but
still
i mean that transformation into you
would have had first of all i love kevin
smith's face the whole time just
trying not to cry he's just getting more
excited but yeah i mean you
like you do have that moment where
monica takes the bullet and she looks at
wiccan and says something like nice
moves or something like that or nice
tricks
i could see how there might have been a
segway where they are working together
and they even said that they had ralph
working with them as well
which would have been pretty crazy but
there it does sound a little bit like a
goonies
little ambulant entertainment type of
adventure and then you would get that
payoff with it but i wonder why they
ultimately didn't go with it because
we're going to find out too much
is that no secret 10th episode that's
why it might have been a little too much
kept it contained
but we'll see that would have i would
have loved that uh
just for some theories to come true this
rabbit senior scratchy is agatha's
familiar
in supernatural lore in witchcraft a
familiar is kind of a companion entity
who assists the witch in carrying out
their dark magic often it takes
gotcha an animal in this case this
familiar is a secret demon transfigured
into a rabbit
not at all harmless as i gathered from
his carnivorous appetite
and tasked with guarding the darkhold as
i noted by his
placement on that altar now american i
would have been so cool tells us that
shackman intended on a stomach turning
body horror transformation and
gooney set piece tells us that they shot
a kind of stranger things-esque scramble
between these kids and a
hell beast i wonder if we'll ever see it
yes timeline wise i assume this would
have been after monica pinned yeah of
course
necklace and around when billy and tommy
went outside to help actually perhaps
billy's sensing wanda's choke spell
before she actually did it in the
following scene could have been a result
of this whole re-editing shackman said
that he had to cut the sequence because
it would have been too big of a detour
from the main action of the finale
episode which he said they finished
editing just two weeks ago
after most of the season was already
locked in meaning he couldn't go back
and erase any of that setup he had done
for this rabbit sequence
so were we right about senior scratchy
bane
yes yes eric that actually brought up
the idea of the rabbit being mepisto too
matt shackman
you know what it's probably better that
the rabbit
wasn't like didn't turn into a monster
because then you'd have everybody going
now that's mepisto for you
yeah shackman's laughing headshake there
tells us that while senior scratchy was
intended to be a badass shape-shifted
monstrous hell demon
that he's not the badass shape-shifting
monstrous hell demon
don't worry he'll come one day eric said
various signs throughout this series
and in its post-credit scene do still
point to mephisto's possible arrival in
future mcu titles he'll come more on
that in a video coming out soon either
way
it's not the end of one of these
monsters
not just nebulous beings like dormammu
and other dimensions but in this world
little scratchy hellspawn invoked by
satanic witchcraft now i do not consider
deleted scenes to be firm canon
but that this was actually shot that
this was part of the overall creative
intention of the story
and that one division's success makes
shackman a golden boy whose ideas marvel
studios will adopt more and more going
forward
tells us that more but we'll be going in
this demonic direction more in the
future
i mean i still think it does answer the
question though of who
senior scratchy is because they are
building up that rabbit throughout the
whole season
and due to whatever reasons they had to
to edit it out
it's not in there but it does fill in
the blank this is one of those rare
cases where i'm like well there is
actually a direct answer to who the
rabbit
is yeah there's a true nature being
revealed here
yeah so i i i would say that the
information
about the rabbit could definitely be
viewed as a piece of cannon for marvel
oh yeah especially with the consistency
across all the other details in that
finale episode in the show itself
yeah yeah i think that makes sense and
yeah i i suppose if they did go down
that route it would just open up a whole
new can of worms or questions
where are we going to the hell dimension
they're trying to put a closure on this
yeah
jackman actually revealed much of this
series was reconfigured after
it was shot they originally wanted to
release the first three episodes all at
once
and at one point ten episodes were
planned and things were constantly oh
really and getting re-broken
story was changing especially a lot of
the real world stuff and the finale
um there was a lot of of experimentation
going on and sort of
trying different things out um we also
at one point had 10 episodes planned and
we ended up collapsing a couple
you know just to to to make the rhythm
feel a little bit better
this explains a lot of the questions you
might have had first that whole theory
that there was a secret tenth episode
nope but also some continuity issues in
the real world scenes that we saw
like norm's awakening moment with vision
showing up described on his
file and despite that not happening
until episode five and then kevin smith
pointed out a line that was inserted
later after principal photography when
wanda told monica in one of the final
scenes
i don't understand this power
but i will yeah notice how elizabeth
olsen's face looks a bit different on
that line compared to her appearance in
the lines before
and after it's real subtle but wanda is
framed a bit closer the lighting is
weirdly even for an outdoor shot her
facial expressions don't
exactly interact with her forehead and
neck as naturally as they do in the
other shots
i'm going to pause this really quick
just to see whoa
i mean yeah i guess it's super set feels
like it could still be the same day
yeah could be yeah i guess now he's
looking so close at like where her jaw
meets her neck and the shadows and
yeah still looks very convincing yeah
yeah yeah
i guess so kevin smith called it and
matt shackman said he was right this was
a digital recomposition the same thing
okay
with robert downey jr saying i am iron
man as he snapped an avengers in game
they shot his face and close up later
and swapped it on his own body marvel's
vfx technology
is freakishly good they are the devil in
the details
support this channel by checking out one
of our great merch options at
newarkstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow me
rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
everything marvel thanks for watching
bunny demons nice
good stuff good stuff scratching that
itch
i mean yeah the biggest one would be the
senior scratchy with the rabbit i know
they also have the pandemic to deal with
and i'm surprised to learn that it was
only
two weeks before it came out that they
had to lock it yeah i'm astonished
especially
damn yeah the amount of people like
yelling at them and like
diving in with theories and stuff while
this thing isn't even actually complete
again
imagine editing this under that pressure
feeling like you have to deliver on the
finale
especially too with just the momentum
and the success as well like just
everything mounting what game of thrones
was over the course of like 10 years
this became in the course of 10 weeks
this is pretty crazy but i loved it i
mean i really watched the finale again
recently and i was like yeah i
really i really do love this so that
bothers me is ralph to this day
that's still the only that bothers me
but that's super impressive to know that
they did so much remixing because
you know i bet you can look in and find
it now but i wouldn't have guessed that
much going and going into it very true
all right guys well what did you think
about this would you have liked to send
your scratch to being here thank you
eric boss for breaking this down
subscribing rockstars you have done so
already subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell
always covering as much as we can in a
given day last but not least
andrew hayes a buddy my dude listen i'm
sorry for getting back to you late i
understand now though
maybe you've already overcome it it's
been a couple weeks
that you uh got hit with david
oh yes and i am so sorry to hear
that you've gone through with
contracting this
yeah but i know you man you're a beast
you're a little wolverine inside there
healing at a rapid pace
so my dude i know that you are gonna
turn out
okay in the end probably come out
stronger and also
serious some seriousness i hope that you
feel better i hope that this summer
you're able to go out and have a lot of
fun i hope
that even while you're under the weather
you're able to still touch yourself to
get a sense of escapism
because that's what this guy does much
[Music]
love